wade miley the wily veteran hits the
hill tonight 10-4 record a beautiful
2.84 e-r-a
here's a little looper into right field
that castellanos has a beat on one down
two two again swing gonna miss first
punch out for miley
for the marlins it is zach thompson 12th
start of the season and of his career
solid outing against the cubs his last
timeout tied a season nine with six
innings only one run allowed
down
the left field line that will be extra
bases for naquin on his horses easily
into second base
for the one out double
nick is hit safely in four of his last
five appearances leading three two hit
games in that stretch
here's a drive right center field this
ball is hit well this ball is gone
well you saw all the pitches that were
inside
to nick casiano's and this is the reason
why
is because if you let him
extend his arms he is going to do damage
look where that pitch is
3-1 pitch
base hit past the diving chism
it's a 10 game hit streak for kyle
farmer
and a ground ball that's through for a
base hit alfaro has a knock first one of
the ball game for the marlins
so here's brian de la cruz throw over
they got him in a rundown
india
barnhart covering first base that's the
way you do it
nicely done by miley and nicely done
by the reds defensively
de la cruz down the line that is a fair
ball and sure hops the wall
aquino gets to it fires into second but
it'll be a double for brian de la cruz
got him
what a comeback by miley
showing bunt
in the air nice bunt miley has to do
some work makes the play
but gets de la cruz to third
round of the third scooped by suarez
no damage done
but here he's down on strikes and
thompson has his second k one down
tyler naquin works a walk good a b for
naked
here's the pitch
and that's ball is grounded to third
down at second they get one over at
first they get two and the marlins have
turned their 109th
double play of this season
and it's a walk to chisholm oh no strike
three call
chisholm can't believe it
miley gonna look like
i'll take it
aguilar passed the dive of india
and into right center field to base hit
and three and two here to brinson and
pokes one out to right field that's a
base hit so back to back one out knocks
for the marlins and they've got two on
here in the fourth inning
first two pitches let's see what he
serves up here
outer
[Applause]
[Music]
he walks de la cruz a one out base
runner must have felt strong enough to
go out there and no hit the tribe
alex jackson to base it into left field
so for the second inning in a row the
marlins have
two on and one out
now the 2-2 pitch squares around again
gets it down miley thought about third
will go to first
another sacrifice bought by zach
thompson
[Applause]
now that's inside for ball four
[ __ ] that'll bring jazz to the plate
with the bases loaded
that hit him got jazz as he hits the
deck but also gets a
pretty painful rbi
faces remain loaded run scores marlins
will take it they're down to run
well aguilar is in the driver's seat
there is nowhere to put him
that's ball four
and the marlins get their second run to
tie it up
david bell will take the ball from wade
miley in a 2-2 affair it's wade miley
easy going yes he is can he get fired up
absolutely
and not happy at all giving the ball to
david bell
it continued into the dugout
where he was
letting it fly verbally i'm sure it's
let me get myself out of this trust me
the batter is lewis brinson
fly ball
yogo akiyama came into the game on a
double switch and xiaogo
makes another sliding catch
the ball will find you
and the reds say thank you very much
two balls two strikes from thompson to
barnhart ground ball biggie has to go to
the backhand makes the play over to
first what a beautiful job by miguel
rojas
had to go against the grain and then
slide cut back and make the throw over
to first
wade miley
lost the command of his pitches and
cessa loses anderson here
up the middle india
farmer
twist and turn and turn it two baby
that's another really good play taking
your time
india
laying the ball out allowing farmer to
make the move
india
lines a base hit into left field good
way to start the sixth his first hit of
the night
line drive base hit right center field
that'll find the gap that goes all the
way to the wall india rounding third
base they're going to put the stop sign
up
as the marlins got to that ball quickly
not a great throw in
second and third nobody out here in the
six red's trying to reclaim the lead
chopper to short this will get india
home it's an rbi ground out for
costianos and the reds reclaim the lead
at 3-2
3-1
and it's a walk
and it appears tyler stevenson will hit
now the right field line that's a fair
ball
one run scores here comes vital to the
plate they're gonna hold up farmer it's
a two rbi double by mr clutch tyler
stevenson
second and third now still only one out
here's suarez
hopped up
right field
farmer
tags at third here he comes to the plate
here comes the throw cut off by aguilar
they've got stevenson caught up at third
base with count the one
[Applause]
that's low for ball four so back-to-back
walks
andy's due for a big hit andy is due
and this one is hit well out to left and
it's off the base of the wall
and he's on his way to second jazz is in
the score
and rbi double for brian anderson
here is alfaro
alfaro base it right field
aguilar is in anderson is held at third
and it's now six to four
double by alfaro here's a grounder could
be two farmer
scoop by bottle that's a double play
four double plays the reds have turned
tonight and oh by the way that's the
most by a reds team since may of 2018.
back to lorenzo to second scoop on the
first another double play
the fifth of the night
will hold it up to see if the marlins
won a challenge
sweet taste of victory
replay style